So we're working with the decision version of vertex cover here.
So as an input, we're giving a graph G with n vertices and an integer k.
And the output is "yes" if G has a vertex cover of size at most k and "no" otherwise.
So the first time you see this kind of use of the if-better function
it might still seem a bit strange to you so I'm going to explain to you what it does
and how we're using it here.
We're using this if-better function to guess for us which vertices to put into the vertex cover
and which vertices we can leave out.
Then we check if the assignment is valid although actually we wouldn't have to do that
but I'll get into that in a minute and if the size of the assignment that we have found is at most k
we say "yes, the graph has a vertex cover of size at most k and no otherwise."
So as you can see, we're putting a lot of trust into this part here of the function
because we're basically trusting the if-better to tell us correctly whether we should
put a vertex into the vertex cover or whether we shouldn't do that.
And that is why I basically said that the computer that has this function available
is extremely powerful because if you can trust the if-better to do exactly what we want for us
which is guess the best possible assignment then of course this significantly changes
the running time of the algorithm here.
So let's do a little quiz--what is the running time of this algorithm here for a graph with n vertices
if we can trust the if-better function to perform as specified and guess the best possible assignment
of 0s and 1s to the vertices.